[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID PABLO COHN: OK, so I
get to do the introduction.
Our speaker today
is David Pablo Cohn.
It would be impossible
to overstate
the impact that every aspect
of his work has had on my life.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I can.
He describes himself
as a failed academic.
He came to Google in 2002, after
writing for previous startups
down into smoking craters.
He finally listened to
Peter Norvig's good advice
and joined.
Started--
PETER NORVIG: But
I also gave you
bad advice to join another one.
But--
DAVID PABLO COHN: Yeah,
on average, we did OK.
I started out by
trying to apply machine
learning to search quality.
And in the subsequent 11 years,
bounced around nearly a dozen
different teams from
spam fighting to .org.
Pablo's internal Google title
was Instigator-at-Large.
And he says he's most
proud of his 20% projects,
one of which was creating--
again, this is your fault--
the first machine learning
curriculum inside Google
as a 20% project, taught
thousands of engineers.
And the other was
that he accidentally
found himself in
charge of Google Labs,
also as a 20% project.
And both of those launched
without ever actually entering
the official PDB.
OK, I'm going to
continue the charade.
In 2010, he spent his
sabbatical working
for the US Antarctic
program at the South Pole,
as the Help Desk at the
Bottom of the World;
left Google in 2013 to spend
more time writing and working
in Antarctica.
Ah.
There we go.
Thank you.
Oh, that's cool all
kind of fun recursive.
You can watch--
[LAUGHTER]
Recently, as last
Friday, was announced
to be the winner of this year's
Palo Alto Short Story Contest.
Grab this last week's
copy of the "Weekly."
There we go, that was what
I was going to show off,
the Instigator-at-Large.
And he is here on the
first stop of publicizing
his just-released second book,
a collection of short stories,
titled "Eight in Three Weeks
and Other Early Stories,"
published by Montemayor Press.
And I'm going to stop
here, because I can't think
of anything I can say that
he couldn't say just as
well himself.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you very much.
OK, no.
I'm going to get rid of the
hat, because that's just
a little too silly.
OK, let's do this.
"Seems like it rained fire
ants all afternoon that day.
They dripped from the gutters
and the old [AUDIO OUT]
and drizzled from the
leaves of the sycamore that
stood a little further
up the mossy rise.
Sometimes, they just seemed to
fall from the clear Missouri
sky itself."
I love first lines.
So for me, first lines are like
that woman in the red dress
who's just walked in the room.
And you have no idea who she
is or where she came from.
You've just been plunged
into a brand new world.
And your brain is
saying, what's going on?
It's screaming for context.
It's screaming for clues.
For me, I guess, first lines are
this crazy romantic invitation
to fall in love.
"No one was willing to say for
sure whether Billy Ericsson's
body was in the boat when
they set it afire that night.
I suppose it was
better that way.
Any certainty one
way or the other
would have raised
uncomfortable questions
about the disposal
of human remains.
And those noncommittal
hmm's from the boys
down at the shipyard seemed
to give everyone enough leeway
to believe that things
had been resolved in a way
that Billy would
have appreciated."
I should warn you, people
tend to die in my stories,
I mean, not like
horror [INAUDIBLE]..
The They die--
I kill them lovingly.
[LAUGHTER]
So sometimes, when you dive
into one of these things,
you're looking for
long-term commitment.
You want to meet a
character slowly.
You want to get to know
them, meet the family,
watch them grow up,
watch their kids.
And if you're reading
George R.R. Martin,
watch them all
brutally slaughtered.
But you're looking for
something that will last you.
You're looking for
half a million words
in 1,000 pages or so.
Other times, you're
not up for that.
You really just want to dive in,
have your world turned upside
down, and find
yourself, like, whoa!
--as you watch the tail lights
disappear off into the dawn,
going, wow!
So I think we have short
stories for the same reason we
have singles' bars.
Turns out, I write
short stories.
I've tried a couple of novels.
"The Heller's
Tale," the novella,
is the longest thing I've
actually managed to complete.
But yeah, I seem to just
write short stories.
I come up with an idea.
I go forward with it.
And 3,000 words later, I'm done.
And there's really nothing
else I want to say about it.
So the way I think this works
is I start out by saying,
I'll talk a little bit about me.
Then, I read you a story.
And then I talk a little
about my writing process.
At least, that's the way I
saw the other authors' talks
operate back when I was here.
In fact, my last day
at Google, no one
knew it was my last day
except for my manager and me.
But it was when I helped out
with the Neil Gaiman talk.
And I was sitting
there in the front row.
And I knew I was leaving
Google to sit down and write.
And he was up there
reading from his new book
and talking about--
and he gave this
awesome amazing advice.
And I was thinking,
there is nothing else
I can imagine wanting to do
right now than write stuff
that would have me stand up and
talk about what I've written.
So here I am.
Whoo!
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
DAVID PABLO COHN: Yes.
Any case, me--
Google.
I was going to be a professor.
I failed, failed.
Applied for faculty jobs
four years in a row.
Five startups in six years.
Four smoking craters.
Found one I couldn't kill.
My dissertation, back in
1992, was on this fringe thing
called machine learning.
Yeah, yeah.
I got out too early.
The dissertation developed an
approach to machine learning
called active learning which,
again, I got out too early.
But yay!
As I said, I bounced around.
As my introducer
said, I bounced around
a bunch of teams, created
the machine learning course,
found myself in
charge of Google labs.
And I'm not good at being
in charge of things.
And I tried to get
un-in-charge of it.
And the only way I could
get un in-charge of it
was by going away
on a sabbatical.
And for various
reasons, I was offered
a job at the South
Pole, being the helpdesk
at the bottom of the world.
And [DEEP SIGH] that kind
of gets under your skin.
You either love it or you don't.
And I kind of loved it.
So two, three years
later, I left for good.
I spent my time split
between writing and working
in Antarctica.
When I started writing, I
was just writing travel blog.
I'd been writing travel blogs
for, like, 11 or 12 years.
And when I was at the
South Pole, though,
there was this thing--
this great thing-- that
I observed happening.
And I thought, this
would be really awesome
if this one other thing that
wasn't true were also true.
But I don't know how
to make stuff up.
I only know how to
write what I see.
And I thought,
someone really ought
to write this story where
the thing that didn't happen
did happen.
And that sat on me, and sat
with me, and sat with me.
And finally, I did write.
And that's actually
"Heller's Tale."
And once you start making
shit up, it's hard to stop.
Because it's so much
easier to write about stuff
that didn't actually
happen than to stick
with what actually did.
So I'm going to
read a story now.
And here's the problem, I
can't decide which one to read.
I was figuring I'd have to
do something Antarctic-ish.
Because, you know, Antarctica.
But I could also do
something that's local.
It's funny and a
little bit bitter.
Nobody dies.
Nostalgic-- the
raining fire ants one,
or "Sweet'n Morbid,"
where people do die.
You all, I think I'm going to
just go with Antarctica, OK?
OK.
This one's called "Artifacts."
And I've got my
reading glasses on.
OK.
Actually, let me just--
before I dive into this--
most of my stories start
with those first lines.
I just write
something down, just
to get a sentence on the page.
And I have no idea
what it means.
And I spend the rest
of the story trying
to figure out what that means.
Like, the fire ants thing--
when I wrote that, I had
no idea what it meant.
So again, we're going
to dive into first lines
that aren't quite so drastic as
the ones I've given you before.
But again, when I wrote
this first sentence,
I had no idea what it meant.
"It was pretty obvious
that the girls thought
I shouldn't have those bowls.
And I wasn't at all
sure they were wrong.
They, the bowls, had
arrived down at the station
under circumstances that
weren't entirely official.
Come to think of it,
so had the girls.
But the bowls arrived in a long
wooden crate with some sorts
of machinery-- honestly, it
could have been tractor parts--
that came down from Ushuaia.
There were the
official parts listed
on the manifest,
the usual dunnage
and then, stuffed under some
of the padding, the bowls.
On some other planet, they could
have been tractor parts too,
I suppose.
They reminded me
of Navajo pottery
but looked like they'd been
carved from spun metal instead
of clay.
Which meant maybe they
weren't bowls at all.
I'd been meaning to
look up the definition,
if only so I could
tell the story right.
Well, whatever they
were, they were
going to get checked
out on the berms
once the folks from logistics
got their parts out.
So I took them, put them on the
shelf of my bunk to brighten it
up a bit, put them
next to the dream
catcher my little girl had given
me before I deployed out there.
When the sun came around
to my side of J-95,
it came through the window and
glinted, threw the light around
with little tiny
spot on green canvas,
like stars in my own
personal planetarium."
I forgot, I actually
have a slide of context.
Just for where we are.
"I missed the
stars, still missed
getting them every night.
Another month here at the
South Pole, and the sun
would be gone.
And then, of course, we'd have
six months of stars nonstop,
and I'd miss the sun.
OK, closer to 4 and 1/2 months.
Twilight on either end would
make up the difference.
But when telling other people
about how things were here
at the pole, we
all simplified it.
Six months of day, one sunset.
Then, six months of night
and a single sunrise.
Repeat ad infinitum, until
the Herc comes and gets you
for redeployment.
Anyhow-- the bowls.
I'd had them for a
couple of months now.
And they'd sort of become
part of the background for me.
There were three of them,
one big and two little.
And they'd nest if you slid
them together just right.
They had a dull finish,
like old aluminum.
And instead of
painted decorations,
there were swirling patterns
cut out from the sides--
a mountain with the sun behind
it, some lightning bolts,
a man, and a
stylized running bird
whose tail stretched
halfway around the midpoint
of the largest one.
I'd had them up there in the
shelf since-- oh, when was it?
Probably December.
But no one had been
in my bunk since then.
Come to think of it, no one
but me had been in my bunk
since November, when Michelle
left a bar of Kiwi chocolate
she'd brought in from
Scott base on my pillow,
as a thank you for
fixing her computer.
There weren't a lot of places
to be alone on the station,
so you tended not to mess
with other people's bunks.
But there had been
some sort of problem
with the cooling
recirc in our pod.
Funny how, even down here,
you needed a cooling loop.
And when the UTs fixed
it, they knocked out
a couple of overhead panels.
So I filed the ticket for a carp
to put up the panels back in.
And the carp brought the girls.
It was still strange to think
of families living down here.
I suppose it was
strange to them too.
All part of the new "now."
We were doing our best to, as
they say, embrace the change.
Anyhow, the girls were fine.
I'm sure they had names.
But they never spoke.
Well, almost.
And at least not to
anyone except each other.
And when they did, it was
in their own language.
Their mother had come down
from some small village
along the spine of Patagonia,
down with the most recent wave.
She'd gotten work as a welder
on one of the vessels--
apparently, she was
phenomenal with metal--
then made her way
south until there
wasn't anywhere farther to go.
And the girls came with her.
Somehow, when they
got to station,
the girls latched on to
L2 as a surrogate hen
and followed her around instead.
L2-- her real name was Laura.
But down here, I
guess we tend to lose
track of the names
our parents gave us.
When she'd showed up at
the carp shop last season,
they already had a
Laura, also a carpenter.
So for a while, she was Other
Laura and, then, Laura two,
before her name settled on
the present two-letter form.
It wasn't a big thing.
I can think of
half a dozen folks
that I only knew by
something their own mothers
wouldn't recognize--
Storm, Froggy, Mutt.
Any case, as I said, I'm
sure the girls had names.
But they just seemed like
L2's unlikely adopted brood,
as they followed.
And we all called
them "the girls."
Straight black hair
framing little round
faces under their
hand-knit chullos.
I thought the older one
couldn't have been more
than eight or nine.
But I never was good at
telling ages of mountain folk.
And those wide dark eyes made
theirs even harder to guess.
So L2 was standing
on the ladder,
poking her head up through
where the broken ceiling
panel was supposed to be.
And the girls were
bouncing on my bed,
chattering at each other.
They'd tumbled into my bunk when
L2 had knocked, pushed past me,
started sniffing and
scouting every corner
of my little 6-by-8 wedge,
like puppies let off-leash.
Sorry, do you mind?
L2 gestured towards the girls
with an air of resignation,
like there was nothing
she could do about it.
There probably wasn't.
Nah, it's fine.
I didn't have
anywhere better to be.
So I watched as she
set up the ladder
and started poking
around the ceiling.
Watched her.
Watched them.
I figured I ought to
try and be a good host
and reached for
a box of gumdrops
I'd picked up from a beaker
who'd left early in the season.
Hey, girls, want a gumdrop?
They looked at me
briefly, with expressions
you might find on the
faces of zoo patrons
who have just
watched a seal bark,
and then resumed their play.
Hey, here.
I pulled one out, threw it.
The older one caught it,
unwrapped the gooey blob,
and sniffed at it.
Handed it to her sister.
She considered me again
for a moment, trying
to determine whether a second
gumdrop would be coming,
then turned back to the
task of bouncing on the bed.
OK, here is another.
She caught this one,
almost without looking,
and stuffed it into the
pocket of her dress.
I could have just left
well enough alone,
but this felt like a challenge.
And, well, Sundays
were slow days.
Hey, girls, let me
show you Something
I thought of the
Navajo-like motifs
on the bowls, reached up to
where the top shelf hid them
from below.
There was a high,
brief, piercing shriek.
When I looked back
down, the girls
had pressed themselves flat
against the plywood partition
and slid as far away
from me as they could,
eyes fixed in something close to
terror on the bowl in my hand.
L2 had ducked her head back
down from the overhead space
and was crouched at
the top of the ladder.
Jesus, Karl, what
the hell did you do?
I looked back and forth
between her and the girls.
I-- um-- well--
nothing.
Really!
I just wanted to
show them the bowls
I saved from getting burnt.
Well, don't.
Christ, can't you see
they're freaking out?
I see.
But I don't know why
they're freaking!
Look, they're just
metal bowls I found.
See?
I hold up the smallest one
so she could examine it
and watched the
girls eyes track it
the way you'd watch a snake
moving through the grass.
They're nice.
Where did you get them?
No, no, wait.
Put them away.
The girls are freaked.
I took the bowl back, moving
slowly, smiling as reassuringly
as I could, as I nested the
bowls inside each other,
lifted the stack to place
in the drawer at my feet.
There was a brief
stampede of small feet.
And when I turned to look
again, the girls were gone.
L2 regarded me with interest.
Well, that was something.
I figured I'd tracked
their mother down
that evening to apologize
for whatever it was I'd done.
She was a sleeper, though,
welding on the night shift,
so she wouldn't be
up until dinner.
L2 had told me her name
half a dozen times.
But I still couldn't
get it right.
Iqueta, she'd said.
But all I could ever
remember was equator.
I finally asked her
to write it down.
Yeah, I'd find Iqueta at
the galley at dinnertime.
But it was about
half an hour later
that Carter came
knocking on my door.
Now, I don't think I'd
ever seen Dan Carter out
in the Jamesways of
his own free will.
Like most of the station's
senior management,
he kept to the
warmth of the station
when he wasn't out in the
field making his rounds.
Carter's primary job
was physical security,
which didn't involve theft
and petty indiscretion so
much as it involved preventing
folks from hurting themselves
or others in stupid ways.
Someone nicked your boots
from the locker room?
He'd put up a notice
on the bulletin board.
Someone set up a jet
fuel-powered hibachi
in the smokers' lounge?
Now, that was his
bread and butter.
So having Dan Carter at my
door on a Sunday afternoon
was cause for at
least a little alarm.
Uh, here to check out
the carps handiwork?
Uh, finally got
something in that
resembles the ceiling again.
Sorry, Karl, this is business.
I understand you're keeping some
sort of demon artifacts here.
[LAUGHTER]
He paused.
It was a measured
pause, calculated
to gauge my surprise
before continuing.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Sorry to bother you.
But Iqueta came at me
like I'd tried to feed
her kids for the Rodwell.
I mean, Megan was
doing the translating.
You know my Spanish is crap.
But the gist was you had some
sort of machine or device here
that was a danger to them--
mm-- the whole station,
by the sound of it.
You have any idea what
she's talking about?
I showed him the bowls and
told him the story of how
I'd ended up with him.
He admitted, he had no better
idea what they were than I did.
You've-- uh-- checked
they're not radioactive?
Wh-- why would I have done that?
Mysterious metal
objects showing up--
who knows where they're from?
They're out of USAP crate
shipped from Ushuaia.
The entire
continent's nuke free.
Don't they check
that sort of thing
when they let stuff on board?
I suppose.
Do you even have
a Geiger counter?
Does anyone here?
Point taken.
But look, these things
are freaking Iqueta out.
And honestly, I
think they're fine
and you're not doing
anything to endanger anyone
in the life-and-limb category.
But wherever she
comes from, they've
probably got some pretty
deep-rooted superstitions.
And these things have kind
of snapped her mousetrap.
You're well in your
rights to keep them.
But I'd take it as
a kindness to Iqueta
if you'd consider
shipping them back home
or, at the very
least, telling her you
were shipping them back home
and making a good show of it.
Could you do that for me?
I said I would.
And he said he owed me a beer
for the favor and said goodbye.
I figured I'd still catch
Iqueta at the galley
and apologize for
causing her kids grief.
I could pick up a shipping
box and some packing tape
from cargo at the
same time and have
the double bowls on an outbound
Herc by tomorrow afternoon.
Shipping them to my brother
seemed like the obvious thing,
not because of the devil thing.
But because, over
the years, his garage
had ended up storing
most of the useless crap
I acquired when it was no
longer practical to drag around
the world with me.
So I threw the bowls
in my knapsack,
stepped into my bunny
boots, and pushed out
through the front door of J-95."
That's the front door
there of a Jamesway tent.
"Iqueta was there
waiting for me.
Well, not quite waiting,
more like preparing.
She'd carved deep gouges in the
ice surrounding the entrance
and filled them with
bits of scrap metal.
The effect was that
of a miniature Nazca
lines painting-- spirals and
pictograms, cut in a half
circle, surrounding the door,
brought into relief by handfuls
of washers, bent wires,
and machine screws.
You stop.
Her voice was
authoritative, commanding,
with a raised palm
outstretched like
an old-fashioned policeman.
She was a small brown
woman with a heavy rope
of thick black hair
that she wore braided
and tied back behind her.
But she spoke with a conviction
that stopped me in my tracks.
Hey, sorry.
I was meaning to come and
find you and apologize
for the trouble.
Carter told me.
I'm getting rid of the bowls.
I knew she didn't speak English.
But I had to say something.
And I was hoping my posture
and conciliatory tone
would get the message across.
You stop!
She said it again,
like a magic spell
whose words had no meaning to
her but held someone's promise
that, if uttered
in the right tone,
would produce the
desired result.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'm stopping.
But I'm getting
rid of the bowls.
See?
I've got them right
here in my bag.
I patted my bag over my
shoulder to add emphasis.
And as I did, her eyes
grew wide in terror.
Her next, you stop!
--was not so much the
voice of authority
but almost screamed loud
enough that the doors
slammed open on J-93 next door.
A couple of husky
firemen burst out
at a run to stop
what they could only
assume was some violent assault.
I dropped the bag at my feet,
arms outstretched.
Her eyes followed
the bag as it fell.
And the bowls emitted a
muffled bell-like clang
when they hit the ground.
By now, Mike was
between us, sizing me up
as an unlikely assailant, but
still using his fire chief's
command-and-control voice.
What happened here, Karl?
He was in my face, ready
to grab, tackle me,
whatever was needed.
It's OK.
Apparently, I've got something
in my bag that freaks her out.
I was telling her that
it was getting rid of it.
And, well, she freaked out.
What is it?
But he didn't wait for
an answer and turned
to where Jake was already
trying to calm Iqueta and assess
whether there had
been any actual harm.
That's when he looked down
and saw the lines of metal
drawn in the snow.
He turned back to me.
What the-- did you do this?
No, I-- I've got these
metal bowls I found.
Carter told me they freaked
Iqueta out and her kids out.
So I was going
over to the station
to get some boxes
to ship them out.
I came out the door.
And she was here with
all this ice voodoo,
yelling at me to stop.
Honest, I'm just as
confused as you are.
Iqueta was talking fast
to Jake, pantomiming
a pushing motion directed
at my dropped knapsack
and the bowls it contained.
Uh, Mike, you speak Spanish?
I'm kind of limited here.
And she's going crazy fast.
None of us did, other than the
usual, una cerveza, por favor.
So Mike called for someone
in the now-assembled crowd
to go find L2, Megan, or
someone who could translate.
In the meantime, it became
clear that it wasn't me
that Iqueta had
the problem with.
It was whatever was in my bag.
And as I stepped clear of the
half circle of snow drawing,
she shook her head
and gestured for me
to go back inside, to take
the bowls, and put them away."
Who wrote this stuff?
"Fine.
I nodded in ascent,
scooped up the bag,
and retreated back into
the darkness of J-95.
Once inside, I slid the
drawer out under my bed,
dumped the bowls away,
and pushed the drawer back
with my foot.
I came out, holding the
bag up, open and empty,
as though I were leaving
the target of a police siege
and wanted to assure
the assembled SWAT
team that I was carrying
no armaments or explosives.
Someone had fetched
Carter in the meantime,
with Megan in tow.
And the rest of the crowd
had mostly dispersed.
But Iqueta still stood
there, like a defiant sentry
at the edge of the carved rings.
And the firefighters
were absent-mindedly
digging the toes of
their boots into the ice.
Carter was out of
breath from running.
He looked back and forth
between me and Iqueta,
sizing up the situation
before speaking.
OK, sounds like Operation
Get Rid of Devil Bowls
didn't go as smoothly
as I'd hoped.
Anyone want to fill me
in on what happened?
Megan translated his question.
And Iqueta burst into
a river of Spanish,
gesturing wildly at me, at
J-95, and at the rings of ice
and scrap metal at our feet.
Mike raised his hand slowly,
authoritatively, for attention.
He was a head taller
than the rest of us.
And even Iqueta stopped
to give him the floor.
He gave, in my view, a
fair and measured account
of what he had seen and assured
Carter that the bowls were,
again, secured in my bunk.
Megan raised her hand-- it felt
a little like we'd been called
out by the principal for
fighting on the playground--
and gave her understanding
of Iqueta's account.
She says the bowls have
demons and that they can't
be brought inside the station.
She says that they have to
stay inside the circles here.
If they get out, they'll
take her and her daughters.
Carter was intrigued.
She said that?
The bowls will take her?
What does that mean?
Why would they take her?
Where?
Again, Megan asked
and then listened.
Because she-- left-- no,
it's like-- it's like left,
but she's saying,
[SPANISH],, which is,
like, landed or went down?
Her husband or the
village or wherever--
there are a lot of
names I'm getting here.
But she left.
And someone wants to bring her
back to wherever she came from.
Iqueta pantomimed
incomprehensibly,
presumably acting out what
she thought Megan was saying."
Pretend I'm pantomiming here.
"Carter put a hand
to his forehead.
Oh, god.
So it's an HR issue too.
Let's go find Linda.
Mike, Jake, thanks for the help.
Think you can go.
Megan, do you have
a few minutes?
At this point, I
think you've got
more of the story
than anyone else here.
We sat together in the
upstairs conference room
as Megan, Carter, and I
repeated what we knew.
Iqueta nodded enthusiastically,
while Megan spoke.
Linda's Spanish wasn't
as good as Megan's.
But it was good
enough for her to ask
a few questions of her own.
It just seemed to be
that the bowls were sent
or, as Iqueta had
had it, had come
to take her and
her daughters back.
That's why there were three
of them, one big and two
little ones.
Now that the bowls had seen the
girls and knew they were there,
they were a problem.
What could the bowls do?
She didn't know.
Couldn't know exactly
without seeing them.
But they were metal.
And it was metal in the
earth that gave them power.
That's why she'd come to
the ice in the first place
when she ran away.
Ice was a barrier that kept
her people's magic off.
She insisted that the
bowls needed to go.
But they couldn't come
into the station first.
There was too much metal
there and they'd get loose.
For now, they needed to
stay where they were,
out in the outskirts, in J-95.
Carter kept shaking his
head in gentle disbelief--
the things I have
to put up with--
but was willing to go along
with any plan that would
restore peace to the station.
We agreed that I'd bring
some shipping materials back
to my bunk, pack
the bowls up there.
We'd get Riley to print a label
for me, just guess the postage.
And when the mail bag
went out tomorrow morning,
I'd meet her at the ramp as
she handed everything over
to the plane's loadmaster.
No hazmat stickers, nothing
fragile, just three metal
bowls with bad juju that
were causing a stink.
The sky was another
bluebird morning, as Poll 57
landed the next day,
probably the first
of six Hercules supply
planes we were going to get.
I'd come down to the
ramp a little early.
I liked watching the planes.
And Carter had given me the
equivalent of a hall pass
for the morning.
Sorry, Bill, I'm going to
be out for an hour or so.
Need to do something for Carter.
I felt the cold on
my chin and listened
to the unearthly
crackling of ice crystals
forming in the air, swirled
up by the enormous plane's
propellers as it pulled
abeam the cargo shed.
I'd almost forgotten
what I was there
for when Riley pulled up
behind me in a Ski-Doo,
dragging two green canvas bags
behind her in the banana sled.
Is that my special delivery?
--she asked, pointing
at the box at my feet.
Yep.
No liquids, hazardous materials,
drugs, firearms, or contraband?
Hey, if I had
drugs, do you think
I'd be getting rid of them?
Just got to ask.
I'm legally post-master on
this godforsaken chunk of ice.
So it's my ass in a can
if you ship something bad.
Frankly, I like my
ass where it is.
I had no idea whether that
was an invitation to comment.
So I just put my hand
over my heart and said,
I promise, no liquids,
drugs, firearms,
or whatever else you just said.
Just three metal bowls.
OK, give me here.
See you tonight.
I hear Baker John's making
cheesecake for dessert.
From my desk in the lower
level of the station,
I heard the Herc depart,
the heavy thrumming
of four big engines resonating
even through the thick walls.
You couldn't hear them land.
But there were three more
departures that morning.
And every time one left, I
felt another light blanket
of calm descend over me.
The past 24 hours had
been pretty rattling.
And my dreams last
night had been restless.
The stick figure man from the
bowls, pulling at my arms,
sliding flat like a shadow
across the wall of my bunk,
watching me.
The running bird, now flying,
circling high over the snow.
Only it, too, was a
shadow on my wall.
I'd woken exhausted and
had to unpack the bowls
just to convince myself that
they were really still there.
The afternoon went
quickly with menial tasks.
And by the time we
knocked off for dinner,
I'd lost myself in the rhythm
of tracing network cables
and reconfiguring servers.
I caught Riley in the
galley as everyone
was lining up for the bell.
Hey, thanks for the
help this morning
with my mystery package.
Good to have it out of here.
Don't thank me just yet.
You didn't hear
about the mechanical?
What mechanical?
Your Herc had a turbine failure
on launch, threw a blade.
Turned around and
set back down here.
They're fine.
They're keeping it
warm until MacTown
can get parts and equipment
delivered-- probably tomorrow
morning, mid-afternoon.
And the mail?
Oh, don't worry.
Offloaded everything,
put it back
in the mail room--
federal procedure and all.
Can't let it be left unguarded.
Wait!
So it's in the station?
Yeah, is that a problem?
Just-- just don't say
anything to Iqueta please?
What?
That your box
didn't go out today?
You've kind of lost me.
What does she have
to do with this?
Some kind of reverse
birthday present?
Oh, I don't know.
It's kind of complicated.
It's a superstition thing.
I promised her I wouldn't bring
those bowls into the station.
Well, they're all
locked up and impounded.
It's federally-protected mail.
It's not like anyone could
get at them except me.
And I'm not going to.
Remember that bit
about my ass in a can.
Is there any way I can take
the box back and keep it away
from the station,
like it's cargo,
or until it's ready to go?
Legally, no.
OK, what if you happened
to weight the thing
and discovered that it
had insufficient postage?
Like, I couldn't come up with
the extra until tomorrow?
God, Karl, that's a stretch.
Can't we just leave it be?
I'll go out first
thing tomorrow.
Pretty much no
one but you and me
are ever going to have to know--
or care-- that it
wasn't already gone.
I couldn't explain why
it was important to me.
Maybe it was the
look in Iqueta's eyes
when she saw me with the bowls.
Maybe it was the dreams.
Please?
Jesus.
OK, after dinner, after
the cheesecake, find me.
And we'll go indulge
in your little felony.
The air in the mail
room had an acid tang,
the scent of something not
quite finished burning.
The bag had spilled
open, as if slit.
And there were scorch marks on
the floor, as if around a patch
that looked like electricity
had arced through.
Shit, Karl, get
the extinguisher!
Is this your doing?
I didn't think it was,
and I told her so,
as I grabbed the red,
metal, CO2 extinguisher.
There was no obvious fire,
at least, not anymore.
But she called an
alert on comms.
And the firefighters
were on their way.
Pieces of mail had been singed.
And Riley dug through the slit
in the bag for the source.
It was my box, blackened
and cut through on one side,
as though someone had
drawn thunderbolts on it
with a flaming rod.
Jesus, Karl, you promised!
They're just bowls, Riley.
Carter looked at them.
They're just metal bowls.
By now, Don was at the doorway
in first-responder gear,
with Jake, Billy,
and Freya behind him.
Riley looked up.
Thanks for coming, boys.
I think we've got this.
But I'd love it if you
could stay with us.
Don advanced and
kneeled beside her.
Uh, maybe we ought to
open that up for you.
Billy, keep a bottle ready, OK?
Billy stood to the side, nozzle
aimed at the charred box.
We backed away, while Don
lowered his face guard,
slit the packing tape
away, pulled open the lid.
The bulls were still
inside, still nested
and undisturbed, except
for shreds of burnt paper.
They were cool to the touch
as he lifted them clear
and held them up for all to see.
On the side of the largest
one were the etched patterns--
the mountain with
the sun behind it,
the man with the thunderbolts.
But now, there was
no running bird.
In its place, there
was an etched drawing
of a woman, long black hair tied
behind her with one hand held
up, like a policeman,
as if to say, stop.
AUDIENCE: Ooh!
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID PABLO COHN: Thank you.
The fun thing, somebody
pointed out to me--
it's like, we actually
don't know what happened.
Did Iqueta manage to,
like, ward them off?
And that's kind of the--
or did-- I don't know.
Any case-- so, yeah.
When I started
that, all I know is,
OK, let's imagine I ended
up with these bowls,
and I had no idea
where they came from.
Mmrr.
So let's see.
Let me go back to my notes here.
What was I going to talk about?
So yeah, let me
talk a little bit
about the writing process, which
I have already a little bit.
In a lot of the stories--
actually, those two that I gave
you just the first lines of,
it's pretty clear
that, chronologically,
the first lines of the story
happen after everything
that's in the story.
It's like, we're at some point.
How did we get here?
We're going to step back
and just walk through.
And I don't know how
other people write.
I figured out how to write
fiction just by writing it.
I took a course with Sarah
Hotaling at Stanford,
"Practicing the
Basics of Fiction."
And the key thing on that
was, just write everyday.
Actually, one of Neil Gaiman's
great bits of advice--
somebody asked-- yeah.
He would say, yes, sir?
The person in the back--
I don't think it's anyone here--
said, so I've also
wanted to be a writer.
How do I get started?
And Gaiman said, well, depends.
What do you write now?
And he said, mostly JavaScript.
And he said, just write.
Imagine you have a million
words of crap in your head.
And you can't get
to the good words
until you've got those
first million out.
So there's this process
called "morning pages."
You get up-- first thing, just
sit and write for 20 minutes.
It's stuff that's going
to get thrown away.
In fact, here, I can show you.
Let me pop over here.
Do I have morning pages here?
Crazy screens.
Maybe it's over-- whoohoo!
So this is my unedited
morning pages.
I've just got a couple of
sentences, a couple of notes
on something I want to write.
Here are a few paragraphs.
Most of it is utter crap.
And most of it will never
see the light of day.
And--
AUDIENCE: You
misspelled my name.
DAVID PABLO COHN:
Different Jeffrey.
I think it's a
different Jeffrey.
I don't think he survives.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no!
DAVID PABLO COHN: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Actually, he was dead before
the start of the story.
AUDIENCE: Are you
going to read it?
DAVID PABLO COHN: Uh, yeah.
That's a really dark one.
I haven't finished yet.
I don't know.
But basically, I
write these things.
And I circle back occasionally.
And the goal is to do
it every single day
and not worry about
it being utter crap.
And so I started doing that.
And I spent the
first couple of years
trying the traditional
publishing route.
So when you take these
short story courses,
there are all of
these literary fiction
journals where you submit.
And you wait.
And you wait six to
nine, maybe 12 months.
And you don't hear
anything back.
And you prod them.
And they say, oh, yeah.
Um, yeah, if you haven't heard
back from us after 12 months,
then it's probably no.
Actually, I just got a
rejection, last month,
from something I'd
submitted in 2014.
So you want to be
a better writer?
You can just sit there, waiting
by your inbox, waiting for--
no, sorry.
We couldn't be bothered
to get back to you.
That is a soul-crushing life.
So what I decided, I followed--
less successfully so far--
the Andy Weir model.
I got to talk with Andy Weir.
And he describes-- he's a techie
guy who just started writing
and putting his stories online.
And people subscribe
to his stories.
And he quit his tech
job to write full-time.
And he was having a blast.
And he had this kind
of serialized thing
that some people said, well,
can you put this as an e-book,
so I can read it all at once?
Or can you make a PDF?
And there's this story of
how that was "The Martian.
And next, you've got Matt
Damon and Ridley Scott and all.
And I talked to him.
And I said, you
know, I like writing.
I don't like this whole
trying to get published thing.
And he said, it sucks.
It completely sucks.
Put your stuff out there.
And I did.
And it was a revelation.
I just created a
little medium.com site.
And I also created a Patreon
page with the promise
that, every month, I would put
one new short story up online
for free.
If you wanted to
support by pledging $1
or whatever a
month, that's great.
But you can read
everything for free.
And it was just
this thing that--
it commits me to have
something that I'm
willing to show other
people once a month.
And it was a
magnificent feeling.
Because I put it up there.
And I may have only
got 100 readers--
add a couple of zeros
for Andy Weir there.
10,000 readers, I think he has.
But these are people
who'd write back to me
and say, I really
loved this part here.
That was so awesome.
And I've been here
or there or wherever.
And it just gave me
these warm fuzzies
and made me want to write
more and more and more.
And two years in, I'd go back
and I'd read my early stories
from there.
And I'd go, I've
gotten a lot better.
as I said, so far, the place
where the arc is right now--
last week, one of my
more recent stories
just won first prize in the
"Palo Alto Weekly" short story
contest.
Now, I don't actually just
put the stories up un-checked.
I have a friend of a friend,
a friend of the family, who
is a professional editor.
And she's a novelist herself.
And I pay her an hourly rate.
I think it's, like, $75 an
hour to read and edit and make
suggestions.
And so each story costs
me about $150 in editing.
But we go back and forth.
And Marilyn is actually--
because you can write
some really dark stuff.
Marilyn has become, sort of,
half therapist, half editor.
And occasionally--
with one of my stories,
"Tales from the Ice," we went
back and forth five times.
And she said, Pablo,
you don't really
know what this story
is about, do you?
I said, yeah.
It's a bunch of guys hanging
around the summer camp
lounge at the South Pole,
drinking and telling
stories of people screwing up.
She said, no.
That's not what it's about.
What's it about?
She said, it's about leaving.
Everyone in this story realizes
that they have to leave.
And it's a matter of
what control they want
to exert over how they leave.
And I looked at the story.
I said, oh, my god!
She's right.
And I changed it a little bit.
And it was a so
much better story.
It was like, ooh.
And when I put that last
paragraph on, afterwards,
it was like shivers.
It was, like, right.
So if you have a friend who
you can bounce stuff off with
or a writing buddy or an
editor, it's really worth it.
But what happened
about six months ago
was Marilyn pointed her
publisher at my medium.com
page.
And I got email from Ed Meyers,
Montemayor Press, saying, hey,
would you mind if we put these
together in a published volume?
I said, but they're already
out there for free on the web.
And he said, yeah, I know.
OK!
And so, we've been
about six months
putting the book together.
And it's really exciting.
And I'm still writing.
And one more note, before
I open for questions.
I don't think I
have anything else.
Yeah, I don't think
I have anything else.
So you can buy it on Amazon.
You can also buy it at
Montemayor Press, directly
at the URL on my website.
Or you can go to
your local bookstore
and ask them to
order it for you.
If you buy it for Amazon,
Montemayor Press and I each
get about $1.
And Amazon gets--
how much is the book?
It's $16.95.
And Amazon gets all of the rest.
If you buy it from a bookstore,
the bookstore gets 40%.
And the publisher
and I split the rest.
And if you buy it from the
Montemayor Press directly,
then they and I split it.
So I'm going to encourage you,
if you don't pick one up here,
to go to your local
bookstore and say, hey,
can I order a copy of
"Eight in Three Weeks"
by upcoming, award-winning,
local author David Pablo Cohn?
But yeah, let me just
open for questions.
Oh, and actually how
many people here were
in my machine learning class?
Excellent, right.
You remember the deal with
questions in the class?
OK, so let me open
it for questions.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
getting paid $1 every month
by a reader.
And yet, multiply that by 100.
And your cost is $150, so you're
losing money along the way.
Economically, how
do you do this?
DAVID PABLO COHN: That's
why I have another job.
Hang on.
I was going to show you some--
di-be-da.
Yeah, that's my desk.
That's my desk.
So I work part-time for
the US Antarctic program.
I'm not at the
South Pole anymore.
I'm working on the Nathaniel
B. Palmer, like, two or three
months a year.
I've got some-- here, let me
do a brief commercial here.
How do we get out of-- escape.
Add.
Human software.
Op, OK, there we are.
And now, I want to
find something from--
PowerPoint is not liking me.
Minimize that.
Find QuickTime Player.
Sorry, I just have to--
aah!
So that's the ship.
This is a journalist with
a drone who went along
with us on the last--
so it's a desk job.
It's a hell of a good desk.
Yeah, and so basically I'm
tech support on a ship.
Officially, I'm a
systems administrator.
But in practice,
what I'm doing is
rewriting the data
acquisition system
that runs all of the sensors.
And we've actually
convinced the NSF
to allow us to open source
it, so research vessels
all over the world can work
with a common bit of code.
OK, let's see if I close it up--
"doop."
OK, next question.
AUDIENCE: So when you did
the machine learning class,
another nonfiction, one of
the things you have to do
is make things unambiguous.
But when you do
the short stories,
it seems like you
were intentionally
making things ambiguous.
And what do you
think about that?
DAVID PABLO COHN:
That's a good question.
So do you want, like, caramel
or double-dark chocolate?
AUDIENCE: Oh, double-dark.
Yeah.
DAVID PABLO COHN: OK.
There are plenty of
these for more questions,
if somebody else wants to get
on queue while I work on it.
I hadn't thought about that.
So some of my stories are--
I guess what it is is
it's paying attention
to what information
the words convey
and being very tuned
into the nuances,
so that if you want to be very
clear, you can be very clear.
And if you want
to be unclear, you
can basically say, warning,
warning-- ambiguity.
And the other person
will actually know.
So yeah, maybe it's
just trying to be tuned
into the nuances of the words.
I hadn't thought
about that before.
Thank you.
And I need to get
you [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: In brief, do you
like, actually, writing?
Or do you enjoy the more the
responses to your writing?
DAVID PABLO COHN: I like--
actually, I don't particularly
like the sitting down
and plowing through.
What I like is when
I get that hook.
It's sort of like when you're
surfing and you're-- paddle,
paddle, paddle.
And you don't get in.
Paddle, paddle-- and then, when
you paddle and you get the wave
and you see where
the story is going
and it's just crashing
towards the end
and you hit that last
line, you go, yeah!
nailed it!
That's the real endorphin thing.
And yeah, hadn't
thought about that.
Cool.
Good question.
Oh right.
So I've got a couple more of
the dark chocolate and a bunch
of the caramelie things.
Oh!
AUDIENCE: Caramel.
DAVID PABLO COHN: OK.
I think they're caramel.
AUDIENCE: Chocolate.
DAVID PABLO COHN: Dark, yes.
Whoop.
Anyone else?
We good?
Oop.
And I can give you a
couple more paragraphs
at the end, once we're done.
AUDIENCE: So you
describe the way
you do your short
novel by having
an interesting first sentence.
DAVID PABLO COHN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think, if you could
invent six interesting
sentences like that, turn that
into a novel, saying they all--
DAVID PABLO COHN: No.
AUDIENCE: --have to be
part of the same thing?
DAVID PABLO COHN:
No, the problem
is that I can't seem to
get stuff to hold together.
I have a novel that I've
rewritten four times now.
And it's just, like, there are
these beautiful short arcs,
but they don't line up.
I can't get the person--
he's supposed to be
in Monrovia, Liberia.
But the way the story
goes, he's in Thailand
with absolutely no--
why would he go to--
yah!
And these two
people actually are
supposed to be the same
person for this arc to work.
And I can't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Martin has a process
where he rewrites every novel,
like, umpteen times, which
is why it's slow.
DAVID PABLO COHN: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But a writ--
AUDIENCE: Maybe eventually,
it will work out.
Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: A writer's
existential question-- once you
have those eight
sentences, how long do
you think it would be before
you can throw a machine learning
process at it and come out with
stories where it's hard to tell
whether I wrote it, Pablo wrote
it, or a machine in the cloud
wrote it?
DAVID PABLO COHN: I've
read some draft novels
that I think were at
that point already.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess the question
is, how long will it
be before we can
get something where
we can't tell who wrote it and
we'd actually like to read.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID PABLO COHN: Yeah, I think
we're actually out of time
here.
So anyone else?
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Whoo!